what's the map element is this big new
key bomb thing if it apparently you get
the moors it'll hit it set it off and
take out the bridge yep basically it's a
similar to the sort few daughters you
get on the [ __ ] Acula Sports Go admit as
similar to the make Myers few daughter
this is matt dependent and there yeah
yeah based on morris traitement destroys
the [ __ ] and anyone that's on the
bridge is there's also dead no top Abby
domination
[ __ ] you generally raging I mean I'm
gonna use the no safer because you guys
want to see it it's actually comes and
built with us site which is essentially
a tracker site Oh guys what chakra says
pressure you guys are aware right that
big Newton thing in the middle office it
sounds little dragon off from cod4
that's what sounds like wow that's
actually actually has a very similar
yeah as a very similar noise yeah right
yeah by think it kind of plays and
famous what's wrong you how it plays the
same as I dragon up maybe a little bit
more power home back it stood open to
see I'm really worried the Stephanie guy
here oh good oh no oh I don't have to
cope for those of you who are unaware
there's actually a massive look on the
middle of the bridge here I pray sorry
been through this but when you get near
the nook you're a bap sort of goes away
due to the mediation and makes us on
Reed eating sound but there's a way of
justifying the nuke it also destroys the
bridge and then announced by getting the
more mortal shake few dollars and then
and then it goes up it does the job for
you as rather annoying when you're
walking over where I don't see the doc
on this absolutely be new stuff still
being used then in the dot on the sniper
rifle which 110 anchor you know is it on
the roof God
where is he let's drop yes Oh through
doors right here we go and I still that
one there someone there I'm throw it
down here okay the caps of items to the
train kill 35 kelvis I can still do it
still did one name though and order they
are I can't face not lookin real
apparent I'm just running around just
trying to find them at everyone's
killing them I should just stay in the
one place because at one point they'll
just gonna spawn that yeah I'm purposely
going to in six to make sure that you
don't do this I definitely took a
question about awareness you definitely
want to play we've blocked great
awareness like that if you know where
the other team were coming and lot you
can position yourself at yuddam that
needs have a better shot Eskimos Eskimo
more yes I have to think of the nuke
here it comes long-term orders I don't
know the way there's a good captain
actually well you know once the water
coming really there we go Thank hit me
yeah another bridge do for the boys